a long time ago now but uh it's the
first time that i've seen you and in
person as well so
i hope it's a good one for everyone
um
right if we go on to the agenda
attendances i've had apologies from
councillors
kevin proctor
and denise weston i don't know whether
there's any other apologies
uh no other apologies have been received
yeah i should have mentioned that
we are being streamed live
and so just be aware that that is the
case
item two is
the minutes
um the 10th of november 2021
is everybody okay
with the correct record yep thank you
item three he's dead
we don't normally but if you've got a
point you you raise it
thank you chad um there were a couple of
points uh covered in the minutes where
um
we were advised would be uh informed
back to later date
um
there's a couple in particular that
jumped out one around what would the
impact
what do we think inflation is going to
be because the
uh council finance assumption was 29
when we last saw it and the question on
is that
are we on a fixed price energy tariff as
a council or or not and we were advised
that we would
um have answers coming back to us
thank you
yeah i mean i think obviously
um
this is the last ordinary meeting we did
have the budget meetings
and we've got
um
that on the agenda tonight
but
okay thanks
okay
thank you
item four
is questions from the public
i have received one um a late one and it
was
mr stevenson who was with us with regard
to the cladding
issues
and um
he's asked
a question of uh tht
um he was not satisfied with the
um the answer that was given
and
at the last meeting scrutiny meeting
so we have passed that on
um
to to tht
and
um i'll come to that uh on the agenda
item which
you know you have been informed that
that has
been
um you know off the agenda and will come
back on march but i'll i'll say some
more about that when we get to it
item 5 urgent business which i don't
have any
and
item 6 is the homelessness
in
trafford
so i think it's over to you you you have
given us a report
which we're grateful for would you like
to make some comments on on that
yeah caroline's going to do
the introduction right thanks caroline
okay yeah so i'm caroline siddall
housing strategy and growth manager i
think we've met before our previous
scrutiny committee i haven't been asked
any questions this time from the from
the committee so i've just come with
lots of data to share with you and then
i'll open the floor to questions
so just for information as of the end of
quarter three which was the end of
december we had
777 homeless applications received in
that quarter
um
138 of those went into the main
homelessness duty which is the the duty
at the end of the prevention and relief
um
legislation
we also received
5579 emails into the housing options
service trafford
we received 11 195 telephone calls
and 80 people visited the reception
and we dealt with 114 out of hours and
calls as well
in terms of bed and breakfast placements
as of two days ago the 10th of january
in the amblehurst we had six single
males placed in there and manchester
city council have 43.
in the premier inn there isn't anybody
in
for either manchester or old trafford as
of two days ago
just to give you some idea of the
average length of stay for those placed
by trafford in bed and breakfast um
the average length of stay is 22 nights
uh out of bar replacements which i know
we've covered previously but some
information on that um since the 1st of
october we've received 111
section 208 letters which is a
notification from other local
authorities that they've placed in
trafford 110 of those were from
manchester one from cheshire east
as of the 10th of january so two days
ago we've got 25 individuals placed out
of borough 20 of those are in a scheme
that we lease which is just outside of
trafford in salford
in terms of our bed every night
provision there's 19 individuals in our
bed every night provision as of the 10th
of january and we had three successful
move-ons in december
currently we've got
6446 people on our housing register and
97 were rehoused
so that's all the data that i've got
which i'll share with you in the minutes
um
i know that the committee obviously
interested in homelessness so opening it
up if you wish to have some more
detailed briefing or training around
homelessness and the legislation and how
it works um our staff in the housing
options service trafford rob miller the
service manager um will be willing to do
that also
if you want to come into host and meet
the staff
and shadow the service you're very
welcome to do that as well so please
contact me and we can arrange that
i know you're keen to also go to the
amblehurst and we did have um
a visit arranged on monday but
unfortunately due to the current climate
we felt that that wasn't appropriate
what we can offer though is one to one
um visits to the emerald hurst so no
councillor chelsea you're keen to go i
can go with you rather than having a big
visit for all the councillors um all at
the same time so again if you want to do
that let me know and we can arrange that
on a one-on-one basis
any questions
yeah i just wondered how quickly you
respond to homeless applications
so if an application's taken that day
really um you know if someone comes into
the reception or makes telephone call an
email then it's addressed on that day so
all the information will start to take
place on that day and it does take a
while to gather all of the information
that we do need in order to build a
bigger picture of the situation but um
you know on that day so they responded
to on that day
thank you
thank you um just my usual question i'll
take it um
hey that'll be great and if you send
some dates around i'll have a look um i
take it the people in the amblehurst are
being checked on to make sure
you know they're okay and they're
getting the support they need yes
definitely yeah that regular uh welfare
checks are taking place in terms of
trafford we make those telephone calls
um at least once a week if not you know
more than that more regularly for those
that need extra support and manchester
we're still doing those joint visits
with manchester uh every quarter to do
those welfare checks jointly but they
are ensuring us that they are they are
doing those welfare checks more
regularly and uh following from
following on from the pandemic um we did
create a checklist that manchester are
now using to make sure that those people
that are placing the humble hearse have
got the necessary support they've got
their benefits set up they've got the
medication that they need and they've
got the necessary contact details
and just to echo what the chair has said
i mean i know we're here to provide
challenge but no doubt your team have
got a very difficult job to do with all
those you know inquiries and very you
know high demand and low supply so i
think everybody on the committee
appreciates the work you do so thank you
to the team thank you
councillor carter and then councilwood
thank you john thank you caroline for
that update um just a couple of
questions about the
data and i don't want to create a load
of extra work but
as a non-expert in this area seeing raw
numbers i don't know how to interpret
them is it possible without a whole lot
of extra work to put year-on-year
comparatives on them when reporting in
future so yeah we've got quarterly data
that we can share with you we've got the
annual data so we can show you
comparisons uh i haven't got greater
manchester's uh data so i can't provide
you with with that um
there's a whole raft of kpis here which
i i think are trafford so yeah yeah
with what it was the year before we can
see is it getting better is it getting
worse is it staying the same
um it fluctuates if i'm being honest in
trafford um it goes up and down and we
have seen a significant increase in the
number of telephone calls and emails
that the team are dealing with
so but i can't seeing you and your
direction would enable us to scrutinize
better um and i think you said average
length of stay in bed and breakfast was
22 nights but that's radically different
from what's in the report so the 22
nights is for the singles
it says four
and that may be families
so when it comes to families it says
four for singles and 15 for families so
neither of them are
22.
all right four for families and fifteen
for singles
um
just seemed significantly different from
yeah the data has been updated since
that was circulated to you because as i
said i quoted two days ago so we updated
those that data for me to come today and
update you
that information was gathered at at the
end of december
but the more up-to-date figures i read
out to you i'll circulate in a minute so
you've got more updates updated
information and certainly
if you want some comparisons to this
time last year so you can see
how whether or not it's gone up and down
we can certainly do that as well thank
you
chair it may also i mean the the data
greater manchester i'm sure is publicly
available so we could probably pull
together a comparison if required but
obviously local authorities are all
different so
not sure what we'd necessarily gain from
that but it is something i'm sure we
could pull together thanks yeah i think
manchester's twice the size of buddhism
population so it's going to be skewed
you know you will get a feel of it i
mean and just for clarity i wasn't
asking for great amounts of purely for
traffic
i mean great as councilman said um you
can look at all the national figures in
terms of homelessness online through the
gov dot uk it's all available however
it's about three months
um
it's three months ago it's not so it's
not up to date is what i'm trying to say
so yeah we can certainly provide you
more information in terms of trafford
and and comparisons from last year and
the previous and these quarters that
have come up yeah thanks councillor both
thank you
a couple of questions
you may answer it sometimes i'm quite
sure but
we've got to
43 matches
upstairs
no um
there's 43 currently placed in the
amblehurst
and we've received 110 section 208
letters from manchester from the 1st of
october that notifies that they've made
placements so currently it's 43 but over
a period of time since the first of
october 110 placements have been made by
manchester united
is it because
i suppose
so manchester is a bigger local
authority they have a huge issue when it
comes to homelessness currently they've
got around 2000 people in temporary
accommodation 350 living in an emergency
and b b accommodation which compared to
was his significant
manchester do place out of borough in
various authorities across greater
manchester and wider than that um
we're probably lucky that we don't get
as many placements as others because of
the cost of rent rents in trafford
compared to other boroughs such as
rochdale and oldham where they've got
significant
number of people placed in that in those
boroughs there but yeah it's it just it
just depends on on the and on that
individual and the needs and what's
available at particular time and
manchester do struggle
so they do make placements out of
borough
and the second question
would you happen to know what the
average cost
is for keeping somebody a homeless
person
good question
in traffic it depends if we've got a
manchester united match on um because
the hotel prices uh increased
significantly but on average i'd like to
say 60 pounds but that could go up to
anything over 200 and but where we can
we try not to use bed and breakfast it's
only an emergency situation we have a
number of temporary accommodation units
that we lease from housing associations
and private landlords across the borough
that are significantly cheaper in terms
of rent so we do only use bed and
breakfast in emergency situations
chair it's also worth noting that any
cost
of temporary accommodation is generally
covered by housing benefit anyway it
wouldn't be covered by the council just
to just to clarify that because the
majority of people in temporary
accommodation will be in receipt of
benefits
so the cost of the council is normally
minimal
there is a cap on how much they can
have though isn't it
not with temporary accommodation
yeah yeah thank you thanks
counselor barry winston
uh thank you chair i just want to
encourage um members of the committee to
take up the offer to go and see the
uh the day-to-day work that's just the
nature of all committee work we we do
tend to get not bogged down we do get a
bit data driven and cost driven um and
i've done the the visit to host and
nothing puts a human face on this and
likes seeing families who have nowhere
to sleep on that night so i'd encourage
the members of the committee to go and
to take up the offer and i'll be taking
up the offer to go to amblehurst yeah
but i'll be into a shepherd please
contact me thank you thanks chad
jill
yeah i just wanted because i've come
into this when we've already started
looking at homelessness i wondered what
the purpose of this in scrutiny is
whether we're tracking it or whether
we're looking at if we're dealing with
it properly and i wasn't quite sure what
the purpose of this this data is for us
it would seem very important that we
track it especially with the increase in
fuel cost it seems very important that
we track the effect of that on
homelessness but what you know what was
the aim of
well thank you
i think it was that
we were concerned particularly
through the pandemic um what the impact
of the pandemic had been on homelessness
and
we we did have a first meeting about 18
months ago and we did all say that we
would like to be able to track
what's going on so
basically that that's that's what we're
doing and uh
and of course there's there are
questions that are asked and
you know i think we want to ensure that
we you know the council is doing the
best that it possibly can
for for those homeless people but that
that's the reasoning behind it
um
could could i just ask
you know
it's stated in in the report i know it's
slightly different but
688 homeless applications received
so
other people who are refused i mean the
applications
um
you know do you over you obviously go
through the applications and then you
have to make decisions on on whether
they are
what you would term genuine homeless or
they're living
you know in in some
places yeah yeah so there's many many
reasons why an application would be
taken um and we don't refuse anybody who
wants to
to start that process and have that
application started majority are only
only advice only because they might not
be homeless or threatened with
homelessness within 56 days which is the
legislation around homelessness some
people are homeless
very in different levels of different
applications so no one's refused it
would it depend at what stages to where
they would be in terms of the duty and
as i said i think it'd be useful if you
want to know more about homelessness we
go through that in more detail in some
kind of training or briefing session
where we go through the legislation
because initially if um you are
threatened with homelessness but you
have somewhere you would go into a
prevention duty and the staff have 56
days to prevent that homelessness if
after that stage
that's not happened they go into a
relief duty where we believe that
homelessness and that again if that
after 56 days they would then go into
the main duty um and we have again a 56
day period to find um permanent
accommodation for 12 months or more so
um
as i said no no applications are refused
it just depends
on the circumstances around the
application as to whether it goes into
whichever duty or whether it's just a
housing advice case that's opened and
then closed because that person's not
actually homeless
thank you i think somebody asked last
time about
whether we've seen an increase in female
homelessness and i just wondered if if
you collect data about age gender
um over a period of time if there's been
any if you've seen any patterns or any
changes in in that yeah we've not seen a
significant increase in number of
females i think the question was asked
by councillor procter and it was aimed
around domestic abuse specifically
because nationally it has been reported
that that has increased and we haven't
seen a huge increase in in that in
trafford um
however not all domestic abuse cases
come directly to host they go through
other other um ways through
the traffic domestic abuse service
directly or through marac but
if the committee wants to set you know a
certain
set of of kpis of data they want going
forward then we can start reporting on
on that um what what's happened i think
we know we've been invited to these
meetings we've been asked a number of
questions we've given you data and then
we've come again with more data and
that's been added to because other
questions has been asked so if we want
to make sure it's consistent and we're
tracking it maybe if the committee have
a look at what data you actually want
and then you know i can go back 18
months two years and provide you a list
of that date and then each committee
whether you need need someone from my
team to come or whether we can just
provide you with that data and you can
then have a look at it as a committee
yeah thanks for that i think i think
that would be really helpful
and i think we need to obviously
um you know
discuss that
on what we would like to be able to
get out of
these meetings and all that information
and the kpis and all of that we we we
can have a discussion and then come back
to you yeah but thanks very much for all
the offers so
councillor dagnum
hi um
just to um go back to what councillor
oxford said um
it is always very interesting to hear
from you we are always very grateful but
it would seem to me that
a paper report submitted that we discuss
at scrutiny and proposed questions that
we then send by email
would
perhaps save a little bit of work and
time and also reserve a little bit of
time for committee um
but i appreciate this might not be the
forum to discuss that but at some point
i would like to discuss that thank you
very much thank you thank you
yeah okay any other questions
okay not a question uh chair just a
comment and to finish on a positive and
i'm sure some of you may have already
seen uh some of the uh social media
today but to finish on a positive um we
have officially opened um
the balcony today in timpani which is
um 30
social rent apartments um which is the
first in traffic for a very long time so
um from a homeless perspective and
considering we can we're talking about
that at scooting this evening i thought
that would be some positive news to end
on and the fact that that will obviously
go towards helping alleviate the
situation that we're faced with thanks
well thank thanks for that james um
obviously that is really good news
um
we need to do a lot more as well don't
we
but it's yeah it's a really good it's a
really good start if i can say chair
with his face looking at us i'm sure
there's no better tribute to ray balker
than something like that yeah i
appreciate it yeah yeah definitely
yeah
okay well thank thanks very much uh for
coming along tonight uh it is much
appreciated and we will get back to you
as well
thanks
um right
so the next item on the agenda is
item
yeah by
uh item seven which is acm cladding and
we have
really deferred
that um i think it's unfortunate that
we've we've had to do that um
but the there was some misunderstandings
around the letter
between
between us all really i'll take
responsibility for it but um
the the letter hasn't gone out yet but
it it is
it will go out this week
uh and
uh we'll bring it
we will we'll
invite within the letter we're inviting
the chief exec and the
chair
of uh tht to come along to our next
meeting which will be
in march
um and
hope hopefully you know we'll be able to
uh discuss with them the whole issue
uh around the high-rise flats and the
cladding and
etc
and so i'm sorry about that
it is one of those things i think
um
you know we we are short in terms of
officer
um
because fabiola's um left us now
and so so we're down to
alex
um and john addison really
as scrutiny
um officers and and it's very difficult
because holidays come around and they
need holidays as much as anybody else
fairness for that reason i don't think
we'd have got a response if it hadn't
been gone before christmas anyway
frankly yeah i think you're probably
right so i do apologize for that um but
um you know hopefully uh we'll we'll be
able to do it justice in in march
yeah
louise
well we'll be able to return to this at
the end of the meeting i don't want to
take up the body of the meeting with it
but i would like to discuss it a little
bit further
i'd prefer to raise it later if that's
possible it's more to do with internal
work into scrutiny than it is of any
public interest so i just think it might
be better later on
is that okay with that
yeah thank you
right we'll we'll go on to
um item eight uh the carrington relief
road
and we've got adrian with us tonight and
thank you thank you
the executive member who's got
responsibility for this i think the
projector has gone to sleep
so long
oh there it is
[Music]
uh so uh i think if council wright wants
to reduce it or shall we go straight to
the presentation
all right right great those come up um
so thank you chair um uh good evening
councillors um
and um yes this uh is a presentation
concerning the uh an update on the
countdown relief road
and it really follows on from a report
which you've probably seen to the
executive
in september
which
really i suppose brought things uh up to
the present position and also considered
um route options
and the next steps with the uh with the
road
and the tenant um infrastructure um so
what i'll intending to do is give some
of the background
of kind of how we've arrived at wanting
to
uh plan and improve uh transport in this
area
um
some of the rationale for the approach
taken how that fits in with the kind of
wider transport strategy
taking a look at route options for the
road itself and then
the next steps so
that's the intention
so just in terms of kind of how we've
arrived at
where we are um well a a road or a at
least a a
kind of transport improvement in this
area has been cancelled policy um well
for 10 years now so the 2012 core
strategy
proposed
a good number of transport improvements
around carrington
and certainly a link road was very much
part of that um with the aim of
alleviating congestion um and improving
uh other modes of transport as well
and that was partly linked to
uh the opening up of the former shell
petrochemical site so that
kind of closed down in the 2010s and by
2012 was starting uh the potential
redevelopment in that area
um and
really a key part of that
was the concept of a relief road which
would take traffic away from the uh very
very narrow and congested
a6144
and
just providing not only more capacity
for traffic but also a much safer
route for uh cycling walking and public
transport as well
so that was sort of the initial initial
concept
some of that has then been amplified
really by um the recent places for
everyone plan so this is the greater
manchester spatial framework as as
renamed
and within that um there is a
significant new development planned in
around carrington and partington so
around about 4 300 homes in the planned
period uh potentially up to 5000 new
homes overall
and about 350
000 uh uh square meters of employment
space and and if you're more familiar
with square footage that's of course you
know about three and a half million
square feet so so a lot of employment
developments as well
um
and um
whilst this area uh does include quite a
lot of brownfield land from the former
industrial activities in the locality
there's also new land which uh places
for everyone will allocate and and some
of that
is green belt um
and that will also just sort of add to
the case for additional transport
infrastructure in this area
now none of this happens in isolation so
when we're planning transport
improvements
we do so in the context of wider
transport strategy and particularly in
the context of uh of greater manchester
uh transport um and so really the the
governing the overarching approach to
this is the uh transport of greater
manchester um 2040 uh uh transport
strategy um and within that one of the
projects within that is carrington
relief road and that is within uh also
appears within the delivery plan
um
and as i've mentioned
part of the rationale
for the road is certainly we will have
you know existing problems of of
congestion and unsuitable kind of um
routes for particularly for uh
hgvs um but also
you know the buses get caught up in the
same congestion
it's a really um difficult route for
cycling yeah
six one four four um and so
with a new transport route that would
include
provision
for much better bus provision but also
really critically safe
cycling as well um and and and those are
um uh
two
factors that are really important to
stress when we're thinking of
sustainable sustainable
travel so the way this sort of fits into
um
kind of overall thinking of of of
transport is is in terms of what's
uh
called the right mix of different modes
and i suppose if you think
back to say 120 years ago the turn of
the the last century you know you had a
transport system that was based
primarily on railways perhaps tramways
um uh
water in terms of canals rivers uh and
sea um and then really probably what
we'd now call the last mile dealt with
either by walking or by horse transport
um and so that was the kind of model um
it's taken kind of a hundred years
really to move
really very radically away from that to
one that is based very heavily on road
transport and particularly reliance on
the internal combustion engine and we've
seen with the the you know the hgv
driver issues through the autumn how
utterly dependent we are
on all of that so
the idea that overnight road transport
won't feature
as part of our transport strategy is you
know it probably it will take time for
us to adjust to a fully kind of
sustainable more low carbon future
bearing in mind that of course those
internal combustion engine vehicles will
also be replaced very rapidly by um
other forms and and zero carbon
vehicles as well
so whilst probably ultimately
where
we need to get to in terms of transport
strategy is definitely maximizing the
amount of public transport
and walking and cycling
road vehicles will continue to continue
to play a part
but even when we think about
um public transport
the really big area that we can go at is
probably around buses because whilst
everybody loves trains and trams and so
on you know that takes many years many
many millions to develop
a decent bus service um is much easier
to achieve and of course there are
plans afoot for significant bus reform
across greater manchester so this is
kind of how
you know this infrastructure fits into
the wider
strategy around transport
and i suppose just to put that in a kind
of local context this is the sort of uh
movement and highway plan for carrington
and partington as whole it's taken from
places for everyone um and and i suppose
the reason for stressing this is to say
well look you know the road is not uh is
not the only show in town there are lots
of other interventions that are just as
important uh and that are also being
pursued so uh you see that the the the
route approximately in the purple line
there we've got the yellow roots which
signify um uh sort of cycle and other
sustainable travel corridors we've got
some supporting roads in black
we've got the
orange dotted line which is noted as
account in greenway but
that is um the former railway line
through this area which joins in via the
viaduct to caddy's head and could in
future play a really important part
of transport in this locality so simply
to say that you know there is a wider
strategy around movement of which the
road is a component
so i suppose just to recap in terms of
that kind of strategic case um you so
you've got large numbers of new homes
planned significant numbers of
employment land
significant congestion at the current
time
allied to that
um and whilst with any infrastructure
improvement there are bound to be
legitimate concerns over its
environmental impact there is obviously
also the opportunity to address some of
those um through a careful design
so turning then to
[Music]
the
process of public engagement
carried out
last year
ahead of the executive report um so this
exercise carried out largely in the
spring um a dedicated
web page was created
there was a video presentation uh there
were leaflets to local residents and
businesses um
there was sort of feedback facility um
and um also direct email to
various contacts
and stakeholders
as well
and and from this
process um we received 123
responses
um a smaller number of which
actually expressed a clear preference in
terms of root options
but what they did highlight is that
as you can see from the pie chart there
that there are
a lot of concerns over environmental
issues as you would anticipate but
equally strong concerns over things like
traffic flow over junction improvements
and then some other matters such as i
suppose some of the the
you know the specifics of of of how the
road will be designed and the level of
information uh available at at an early
stage
so this information
um helped in terms of uh developing
route options um and uh a methodology
um and
uh the preferred option appraisal which
went before the executive really
considered the sort of two
best
uh routes which were termed a f um
and um
that was uh attached to that report
you'll find a you know very detailed
analysis of all the different um options
and and and the benefits and dis
benefits of each of those but but the
type of things that were looked at were
um obviously the transport
aspects of it you know is it fit for
purpose will it do the job um including
those some of the practicalities of
junction design and then we had um
drainage landscape um the the
implications of construction um
geotechnical so ground conditions um
carbon reduction um very importantly and
then also the impact on on heritage as
well so a range of
factors um fed into that process
and um just i suppose this slide just
shows you that the sort of different
routes that were considered so perhaps i
don't know if yes it will show up here's
is you can see the the this this roughly
is the
um the existing
um a6144
um along here
um broadly and so you see a whole range
of different routes but the two sort of
best ones that were then taken forward
the the a
uh and the f um
they both follow uh this line through
the former petrochemical site um
essentially
uh along what was an internal road
through uh what was the shell site and
at this point this is where the choice
rises and you either take a route
northwards that broadly follows the
existing alignment of the road albeit
they need significant upgrading
or you take a a route that takes you
across what are currently
our fields slightly to the south and so
ultimately that was the the the the kind
of choice that was contained within the
uh executive report but you can see that
you know that we didn't jump straight to
that various other
routes were also considered
now um part of um
the considerations as i mentioned was uh
the carbon impact
of each of these proposals and so
amy consulting were appointed to
um
employ a an appraisal methodology and
it's based on on that standard um
for carbon management in infrastructure
um and
what they did was to create a carbon
budget for each of the different schemes
um and that considered um
both the the the construction
um uh values um and then also um the
kind of carbon um sequestration
implications as well so um so to look at
it not only in terms of the the building
but i suppose also that the kind of
broader impacts
um and you can see that perhaps the uh
the the two routes performed
you know broadly similar in terms of the
construction impact um so not wildly
dissimilar
but in terms of the sequestration point
then option
f did perform better and that's really i
suppose just because of the um the
amount of perhaps uh trees and other
vegetation that would need to be felled
along the existing line
of of the the road in order to
accommodate um you know that say like
the cycle ways the footways the the the
realigned carriageway and and so on
um but i should stress that um more
assessment of this point will be
required
as the design progresses
um
i think a lot of concern has been raised
quite properly around whether there is a
an impact on
pete
this area is referred to as carrington
moss albeit that it generally lies to
the north of what historically was the
moss land
um so there has been invasive ground
investigation work and that did
encounter pete in one location um and
that was a depth of about 1.2 meters so
in the light of that there will be more
detailed investigation undertaken but as
i should say that was in in one one spot
in terms of the investigation work that
was undertaken
so in terms of other um uh
sustainability considerations
um you know the the
paths of rationale as mentioned is to
create um modal shift so that you're
actually creating a much better
environment for
buses
and for cycleways um
and things of that nature so that's
really um part of the um
you know the approach taken um
and also uh in terms of particularly the
existing carrington village i mean
either route will have would have
bypassed that and at the moment you have
um both businesses and residents who
really suffer from having very heavy
vehicles right on their doorsteps
and so there's the opportunity to calm
that route make it much better for
either local bus use um for pedestrians
crossing backwards and forwards
and to to make that a much better
environment for carrington uh village um
and overall
there's about 1.1
sorry 1 million pounds allocated so far
in the budget for some of those
improvements within the existing
alignment to to try and make that uh
make that better
so in terms of then uh the next steps um
well as in line with the executive
report um
we'll proceed to uh develop the
preferred option
and also um uh in partnership with uh
the landowner to develop and carry out
what are called rationalization works on
the former petrochemical site because
there's lots of pipe work and other
infrastructure linked to the former um
chemical activity in that area
we're currently working on a detailed
project
program um uh looking at just exactly
what it will take now uh to take this
forward uh through through its sort of
detailed design phases
part of that will uh involve more
traffic modeling to make sure the
junction designs are fit for purpose
will need to carry out more public
consultation
um there'll be an environmental impact
statement
and all of this will
lead to the submission of a planning
application and effectively that's the
next milestone
in this project is the submission of
of an application for independent
consideration by the council um
and um
part of that attendant in parallel with
that we'll be doing um
uh more work on funding so a funding
strategy uh and um you know we have
existing business uh existing grants um
that have been awarded to the authority
but some of those require final business
cases to be prepared so the whole
further work stream around grant funding
and then following this um should um
planning the planning permission be
granted then is i think it's important
to stress that there will need to be um
a further formal decision of the
council's executive um before uh the
project is taken any further so really
where we're at is is um you know we've
reached a key milestone in identifying a
route
the task now is to go away and do all
that is necessary to work that up in
detail do more feasibility work
but the the sort of point at which
perhaps it will next
pop-up at least in a formal sense will
be
as a planning application but in the
road if you excuse the expression
to get there we will need to do as i say
public consultation further updates um
to
our counsellors
and just keep everybody informed as we
can
along the way
thank you very much
that was very helpful
and appreciated uh
yesterday that could make it a bit more
helpful adrian could you go back to the
map that shows the route because i got
very confused this afternoon trying to
work out where it was um
uh
that one or would it be my if you want
to know the approved route it might be
easier to show you the
uh that one which is the
drop me through it
can you point to the map and show me
[ __ ] give this give me some lava
okay so sorry you want some landmarks so
yeah this is the
uh so if i look at the map which is
later with the the later map which shows
all the routes which i think is a bit
clearer is that better
it's the map that doesn't have the brown
line on
right
green
option from
and then this is what is currently known
as the a1 road which is not a public
road
it comes out
yes
yes you may have noticed if you've been
there recently you'll have seen a new
uh very smart set of industrial
buildings
just gone up with a big wide bell mouth
that's that's where that is there
so that's the end of the carrington spur
and that's the way
yes
yes that's where it would join yes
so join the carrington spur and
obviously you've got the set of lights
uh there where you join into um
astronomers
yes
yes so the preferred route would would
avoid that obviously the
um the the alternative which was
uh
i think it's there there we are that's
the issue with what the issue would road
lights which tend to be heavily
congested
no no sorry uh uh councilman sunny so
the the this is the existing carrington
spur
um
and at the moment you end with a set of
traffic lights there
where you can turn interrational mersey
so it's a just before sort of so instead
of
progressing as you would past where the
um
you know the various practice grounds
are
um what you will do is from that point
onwards
progressed to a new route which at the
moment would cross the agricultural
fields
uh yes i suppose i oh it depends what
you mean by the carrington spur i think
most people will say the county spur
ends well
sorry when i've been referring to it
i've been saying that
yeah um
so yes it does miss uh a big section
of the existing road but the the section
that is perhaps the most narrow and you
know most unsuitable bit
i'm sorry excuse me
[Music]
i don't know
is it
i'm not familiar with i'm so sorry i'm
not familiar with that is that
everybody has a wrong number all right
yes sorry
thank you
could you point out on the map where the
peat has been found and what happens
if the too much peat is found that it's
too much co2 if it's exposed am i right
can you just talk us through that please
um yes certainly i'm sorry i don't have
the specific location but it was between
it was in this stretch so between ish
wood road
and the um
uh the traffic the astronaut mercy
traffic lights there
um
so
it's in that location this is the area
so historically the area where which was
the sort of historic moss land was
really round here so
um
the area you would expect this to be
found probably
you know is most likely uh uh in this
locality
um but as i say there was um a
um not
as detailed as you would do
for a um
you know for a preferred route because
you do these tests proportionately but
there was intrusive ground
investigations and it was only found in
one spot
if having done if we do more
investigation which we will
um
we will just have to just see what what
that throws up so i suppose it the worst
case scenario
you do very detailed investigation that
throws up a a lot of peat in that area
um
you know that
you might then need to uh you would
certainly then need to consider the
implications for construction
and suitability of the route in terms of
its construction and you then also
potentially depending on the depth of
the peat also need to consider the
carbon implications of it but really
until we do that um until we sort of get
to that point
probably not worth speculating as to
investigation so more assessments
given naturally england's concerns over
the options chosen is it not through to
do the assessment environmental survey
on both of the possible routes because i
think we're down to a and f and sort of
a
f yes correct
um
a and f and that uh
so that if it becomes close because
it did seem quite close on the already
estimates
um that it's more of a consideration
between the two that's one of my
questions
um i've got the other thing 123
responses from a survey that affects two
is how many thousands of people are
affected by this this is a i'm surprised
at that i would love to see if it's
possible the
what went out what what elicited those
123 responses because it doesn't seem
especially if they were picking a route
of
of such importance that
it doesn't seem right that there
something is amiss with the low number
of responses i don't know what
and maybe
can i ask what the additional revenue is
of two roads we're gonna have a second
road here
um has that been the ongoing maintenance
and uh cost of that has that been
considered
and uh well one last question if um i
mean you mentioned this is part of the
gm strategy but also the gm strategy
also mentions by 2040 the aim is to
reduce
road traffic by 50 percent
um how is the two
congress if we're reducing road traffic
um and i don't think it's the whole plan
isn't bold enough i i personally have
that railway um it comes from timply it
goes to liverpool i know it would need a
huge investment but it's there we've
made all of the bridges over that
railway high enough that we can make
that railway back in and that would take
freight right off the roads it would be
amazing
i just feel that that's an option that i
mean a long-term option but it should be
on the table
um
we are scrutinizing that decision aren't
we
we are we're here to scrutinize we have
to look at it
well there's
yeah there's three points there
thanks chair yeah i'll i'll
i'll go to adrian for a couple of the
answers i think we just need to roll
this back a little bit though in
relation to
in fact what we were talking about
earlier which was about homelessness and
and the facts of the matter is that we
need we desperately need these new homes
um in um in trafford and greater
manchester as a whole and and carrington
is a strategic location for more homes
in greater manchester
in order to deliver those new homes
um
not just do we need people to be able to
access those new homes you've got to
bring the communities that already live
there on board with those new homes and
all of that change
and the communities that live there
particularly in carrington and and
certainly in partington
currently face a situation where
they live in an area that's almost
completely inaccessible they're already
isolated from the rest of the borough
and um it takes them
far too long to get out of their home
either via car or by all via bus or via
cycling
because of the state of the road that
runs through the village
the village of carrington couldn't be
clearer in the fact that they want
that congestion alleviated
as things stand in having looked at all
of the options the executive came to the
decision that option f currently is the
best available option for us to do that
and that doesn't suggest that we are not
committed to improving public transport
improving walking walking and cycling
um but as things stand as a
project to get things off the ground and
to make sure that we can deliver the
homes and deliver the employment land as
well that's also really important as
part of this the road is the best option
and as adrian said in his presentation
yes we want to get away from from road
transport but it's not realistic to
think that that's something that's going
to happen in the next
three or four years we've got to accept
that
we've also got to accept that to enable
public transport to run there needs to
be a road for it to run on
um
particularly when we talk about buses
um and buses simply just cannot get
their way through carrington village at
the moment in a reasonable fashion
because of the congestion that's already
there so frankly
i understand the points that have been
made but we also need to think about the
communities that already exist and the
impact that having a very congested and
inaccessible road going through it means
to them
i'm happy for adrian to come back on
some of the technical points that that
council negros asked thanks chair
well i had three questions
i had three questions and then i can
happy to the end or at the start
in my order
uh get checked you're probably just
perhaps just to add if it assists uh
councillor newgross so um certainly um i
suppose in terms of the you know
council writers highlighted to say you
know
the new homes link
it's really important to stress that um
in terms of the development that was
earmarked
by the 2012 core strategy
that this road was necessary so so
in a sense the the decisions that the
council made 10 years ago
necessitated the road um uh and and
again even at that time um
as part of a wider package of measures
but i suppose it's just important to
kind of put that point of principle back
there
uh i think you asked about the um
you know could we do a more detailed
assessment of of both routes um and i
think the answer to that is you you take
a proportionate approach um at each
level so
when we're doing option evaluation
absolutely it's the right thing to do is
to
sort of hone down
um all of all of the the options so we
started with you know what you can see
on screen now
from considering those you realize that
um you know from an initial level of
assessment that you really have two that
are the most credible
then you refine that further you do some
more work
at a level that's proportionate and
certainly we did the carbon assessment
and whilst i've given a real sort of
short summary this evening i would point
you towards the
um x reports the executive that has a
much more detailed options report
attached to it
and then we will move it to the next
level in terms of the preferred route so
i suppose what i'm stressing is that you
do you do the right level of
investigation
at the correct at each stage
of that um option analysis
and then in terms of um uh the the
railway and indeed the you know the
other measures um uh that's why uh i
included the the the slide around um
i've lost it now but the um
um
showing all the different uh transport
options sorry it's that the one i was
looking for so
it whilst you know we're focusing on the
road because that was the decision that
was made by the executive you know it is
really important to stress that the road
is one component of a much bigger series
of transport improvements and absolutely
uh the railway is in there and it's also
within the um recognized within tfgm's
transfer transport strategies as well as
being a project that that ought to be
pursued
thank you chair
thank you
sorry i'm not really sure where to start
um
i have so much information
um
are we going to go around again so i can
just choose one question
well i don't want i don't want to give
all my questions because
um
i'll i'll just say a few things that
have come up that have crossed my mind
um so first of all i think it would have
been preferable that we looked at this
before it went to scrutiny and i know
that's probably our
dilemma so
that
sorry i beg your pardon this would have
been better
at scrutiny before it went to the
executive and i would very much like to
see the next stage of the plan before
that goes back to the executive back
here at scrutiny
um
the presentation you're given tonight as
adrian said is is very much focused on
the road and that is out of context and
james has given us a little bit about
the context tonight um
i i am very much aware of the need for
homes i wondered so um
if any considerations have been given to
the need for this
uh amount of footage given over to
industrial space post covid as we know
that's had an impact on um
all kinds of businesses and whether the
need for new business space is currently
still relevant bearing in mind that this
plan started in 2012 which is some
significant time away ago i'd like to
know that going forward it's actually
necessary and it's not to do with the
funding for that helping out with the
funding for the houses i'd like to know
that one can exist without the other and
i'd like to know that it was still
necessary and i'm interested in the fact
that you were able to give us precise
details on the number of houses on the
square footage of industrial space but
there are no figures given for the
amount of green belt that's being used
and and when we're looking at things
like this and when we're here at
scrutiny with so many people taking an
interest in this
including the 1 632 people who signed
the petition against the road while
those people at home watching it they
will be asking those questions as well
so
if for us to have a really fair
understanding of it i i need to see both
sides of what we're getting and i'm
finding that the presentation we've had
tonight has given a lot of information
um
as i as i might understand supporting it
but as you know you're bringing it to
scrutiny then you might anticipate some
of the questions that those 1 632 people
would ask if they were here
um so that another question that's only
occurred to me tonight is can i just ask
about the consultation in terms of amy
consulting do we always use amy
consulting
was that put out to tender for other
people i mean it's no massive surprise
that amy consulting gave amy the
go-ahead to do a multi-million pound
um deal so i want to know that that
is either standard practice that amy
consulting
um
are involved in issues where amy will be
the main contractor
and if not then did it go out to tender
and were there other opportunities for
other people to come in and do the
exploratory work
i would echo what rose
sorry rose i've forgotten your second
name
councillor thompson our decca what
council thompson said about
what will happen if we discover that
there is more pete um so if you know and
i think i know i know adrian has said
that that we need
that they will consider the implication
for construction and carbon implications
as well i i appreciate that with his
answer
but coming to scrutiny tonight and
bearing in mind the
amount of interest from the public
i think that those answers should be
those answers should be more
tippy-tonguey than they have been
tonight i think we should be able to
expect
um
some more
figures and some more clarity on
alternatives so i realize i haven't
asked any questions i've just gone on a
little bit
um
but there are just so many things that i
don't understand um
i'm going to leave it there because
obviously other people have got
questions
um
thank you
uh i i can share that that is of
assistance so in terms of demand for
employment uh the pandemic has generally
uh increased demand for employment space
in terms of not necessarily office space
but in terms of business space
that's our experience so far um as a
concert consequence of the pandemic it
might also be something is that specific
to this context or is that generally
speaking that is uh
generally speaking across across
trafford we are experiencing high demand
for employment space um and i think
that's that's a national picture
could we put some could is there any
possibility of putting some figures on
that going forward or some expressions
of interest or something that would
well well i suppose by way of i mean
just as a an illustration i'm sorry i
haven't got the figures to hand but but
by way of illustration the
uh development that i mentioned at uh
which is known as accounting gateway
which is just at uh in this location
here
um that's fully let and was
done so
um very rapidly and and one of the
reasons for that is is
i suppose uh i mean if you just take
things like um online shopping um you
might also take some supply chain issues
in terms of um
you know the need whereas we used to
rely on just in time you know there's a
need for sort of more
um
the companies to have more kind of
security in terms of their supply chains
and um you know arguably there's a
brexit effect so there will be companies
that perhaps previously used to rely on
say a base in france or belgium or
somewhere who will now be locating in
the uk so there's a number of factors
but generally
uh and i'm sure if this is of interest
to me we can come back with more
specifics but to answer your question
there is there is uh more interest in
this area right
i'm really grateful and i appreciate you
you have much bigger understanding this
than i do but i think when when we're
looking at a
such a
um
a contentious issue and we're here at
scrutiny to decide
um
going forward you know we we're obliged
to explore that contention that the
public have raised and i would have
liked to have seen in the body of this
report some of those statistics and some
of that presented
to justify every single aspect of this
so you've identified somewhere that's
currently industrialized which is
managing to operate without the benefit
of the new road so that doesn't
particularly to me back up the need for
a new road
um
what i appreciate you were trying to
what you were trying to demonstrate to
me was that there is that need
but then i would say like you know well
it's there it's providing it's
fulfilling a need it's doing so without
a new road the i mean your planning epic
for example the planning applications
that come before the planning and
development committee will
there are several of those which have a
detailed transport assessment attached
to them which will show why transport
improvements are necessary
uh we're very happy to provide
the the detailed information but there's
quite a lot of ground to cover and i'm
sorry it probably doesn't really within
the you know the parameters of this
presentation have that level of detail
but certainly we would be glad to point
towards you know perhaps some of that
detailed transport information that
shows why
you know we have as i say existing
existing uh developments that are
constrained because of transport
infrastructure limitations at the moment
and and they are supported by very
detailed transport assessments so that
information
could be made available and we'd be glad
to do that if that would help i very
much appreciate that you come tonight
with a presentation of an idea of a
proposal that's already been approved to
some degree by the exec and i think that
perhaps as a scrutiny committee going
forward then we will need to
look at it together and ask some
questions of you that you might um
choose to come back and answer or answer
in another time thank you very much
yeah just just briefly to respond to
councillor dagnall so
as to to just on two points actually so
um the uh the first point is just in
relation to what adrian's just said
which is about the uh what i call
grampian conditions which are part of
the um many planning applications that
are currently in place for
grampian conditions so effectively it's
a condition within and adrian's going to
correct me because i'm going to get the
technical um
details wrong here but in fact
but effectively um we have got a number
of planning applications that are in
place at the moment that have been
granted that can't proceed beyond a
certain point until there is transport
improvements in that particular area
because the road is seen as full at full
capacity following transport impacts
assessments that were done as part of
that planning process
so
we are at full capacity as we as things
stand now and anyone who lives in that
particular area without having doing the
transporting impacts assessment will
clearly say to you we are at full
capacity
and just relating to the petition and
and the
contentious uh nature of this the vast
vast majority of the people who
completed that petition do not live in
partington or carrington and they are
the people who are going to be most
affected by this
thank you
i i do appreciate your point about um
where the people who signed the petition
might come from
but as we all take responsibility in all
of our ways wherever we live for
um improvements um in housing in roads
in air
in air pollution i think it is relevant
that those people have signed a petition
and i don't think it should be dismissed
quite so easily
councillor oxford
um yeah i'm curious that this decision
seems to be based on the 2012 course
strategy which was fun 10 years ago
um
i'm also curious
the evidence about the evidence that a
new rome would only get congestion the
previous evidence suggests that he has
actually needed more power and more
congestion
um
and i'm wondering that the cost of this
road will be justified in terms of the
changes that will inevitably be made
through climate change
and that may be a more
alternative that might be more
appropriate i'm concerned too about
the the hevs that they'll be using the
new word and if there's evidence about
that it actually will
and i'm wondering how this links in with
the greater motor transport strategy
with its aim that more freight will be
moved by rail and water so there seems
to be quite emphasis on these htvs
um
the other thing is about the buses i
mean
yes it'd be great they're the bosses and
people use them people don't tend to
like using buses
um i know there are changes planned but
i think that's going to take me some
time ahead really and i know that we're
in the last
chance of them franchising traffic to
the final one there and i'm concerned
too about the um
the public engagement as well i think
i don't think it doesn't it seems very
strange 123
he responded
can i just make the point again this
decision has been made
for a new road
so
you know that's not going to be going
back on so it's not really
something that we can deal with at this
you know in this scrutiny committee
so
you know i think we've got to accept
that that is okay
but we are doing at the moment so and i
think
that it's appropriate yeah but you're
saying that you know you don't you don't
want that road to be built i'm not
saying that well that's what you do
that's what you did
yeah
thank you chair uh i suppose the focus
is
of attention is on on the route and i
mean it does surprise me a little bit
that you know
councillor dagnall and some of the
others were probably at that meeting
that
their executive approved the route uh
it was certainly not popular uh with the
uh the local people and even i think
what council wright just said you know
people not living in the area but people
breathe the same air or lack of it uh
polluted air whatever
and i think it's important as things are
at the moment you know with the climate
change
that's taking place i just tend to have
an overriding impact as people have
indicated you know that some of these
decisions on
um
were made some years ago in terms of
the plan planning process uh
and also i mean i think it's important
that the
the point about this area being having
peaked and it's it is
a significant carbon sink that
that area uh and it would be i think
remiss of us as councillors to
i mean i understand that the rule has
been approved but at some point you know
we can
roll back
to a situation if we have to uh
intimidate to be able to take account of
the the impact it could
have and
as you can see you know there's a lot of
people against it there's probably a lot
more who haven't raised the issue
at this stage but
it does impact everybody and
i think
it needs to be seriously reconsidered at
some point
as the progress investigations go on
yeah but the decision has been made and
the p issue has
you know
an answer was given to that the there is
more investigation that's
going to um you know be pursued and if
it's found that there is more peat than
what they think there is there then
there has to be considerations around
that
yeah yeah jed yeah uh thanks chad um
god there's tons to get through in this
um
just a first point in a hyper local area
looking around carrington if you
increase the resident population tenfold
and increase the employment space
significant fold you're going to get
more traffic you just are so it's not a
question of is the current road adequate
we're going to dramatically change the
profile so as we might want to reduce
overall road usage in greater manchester
on the northwest in this hyper local
area we're going to get tons more
traffic because more people are going to
live there on a massive scale
i'm excited at the idea of a
separation of
residential and short haul traffic from
through traffic and hgv traffic and the
potential benefits that can make for
all road users and haven't knocked on
probably every door in carrington
village over my time as a councillor and
pre-counsellor
i know that the people who live there
are desperate for relief from this
dangerous situation um
in terms of questions i i share
the view that's been raised by a number
of people about
the first inverted commerce consultation
to get a point one percent expression of
opinion on
um which routes of these do you want
there's clearly something wrong so
in the formal public consultation bit of
it is it possible for us to see before
it is happening
what the scope of it um how it will be
done what the kind of questions are
because clearly there's been a missed
opportunity i think it's been a missed
opportunity
um
and
two other technical questions
there's an awful lot of noise certainly
in social media around you can't build
around anything because it'll just flood
so
specifically on the route f
is there a forecast of will it flood if
so how often
and
[Music]
the option a the inline option last
question chair the inline option um that
was one of the two options that follows
the existing
um a6144
my guess is that if you decided to
dramatically improve and widen and make
safer for all users that there would be
a prolonged protracted period of
traffic disruption which would gridlock
the whole area has that been taken into
account as part of the decision thank
you
um yeah i have to take my hat off to you
adrian i mean first time i've heard the
argument used that will achieve modal
shift by building a whopping great new
road um
particularly given and frankly i have to
say in terms of this presentation
because those chairs pointed out of
course the decision has now been made
as far as this is concerned i don't buy
that argument regarding modal shift the
as has been pointed out the public
transport improvements if they are going
to occur are going to be quite some way
down the road
and in terms of getting onto one's
bicycle i know perfectly well that given
this is going to attract some
significantly heavy traffic
i personally wouldn't want to cycle
parallel to a lot of extremely heavy
traffic both for pollution and safety
reasons um just in terms of the process
i would express some slight concerns
that i was under the impression that the
public engagement event was explicitly
not for choosing a preferred route
in which case i'm slightly concerned
that a decision was made by the
executive on the basis of that or
seemingly on the basis of that
and also
particularly given that the feedback
from natural england was very
clear that the um option f that seems to
be preferred well that is the decision
that's been taken was the most
environmentally damaging
um
and finally i'm sure councillor wright
did not mean to imply because that was
certainly the way it came across that
the only people whose opinions matter on
this subject people who live in
parkington and carrington because i'm
i'm sure that's not what he meant good
but
those are just my comments german thank
you very much
i think we need to
look
um
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i'm just trying to work out what
what is the best way to move forward in
terms of scrutinizing
some of the you know the the questions
that have been asked and uh how we
actually go about that check just come
you know
it does make it a little bit difficult
uh in trying to have a constructive uh
discussion on this when i remember i
think i caught uh the leader and even
castle wright having said they were
fundamentally opposed
uh
to the
the root
f
yeah
you and the council western
well yeah you'd use those words at the
at that meeting
you know it just seems that perhaps
there's no room for maneuver in that
respect i'm only thinking of it in terms
of
further consultation or having the
discussion uh
whether
you're sort of open to
chair if i may um
root f is the preferred option as things
stand there's a lot of work to go on
before we get to anywhere near putting
the spade in the ground
a list of it is on the screen now for
example
um there'll be a full environmental
impacts assessment for a start um
there's a lot of work to go through and
the executive won't take a decision
based on building a new road lightly we
will of course go all through the
evidence base and the recommendations
made by the professionals including the
officers to what the best way forward
will be
um
and of course whether the executive
decides to go ahead with the planning
application or not the planning
application will go to planning
committee and that will be that will be
decided upon by the members of the
planning committee so ultimately the
executive won't have the final decision
on whether this gets approved or not it
will be the decision of the planning
committee to do that
um
and just just in relation to the um
the pete
um issue um and and this is
this is obviously what was the
information that was available at the
time of the council meeting but i'm on
point 7.4 of the council report which
i've just
pulled out of my documents
it does specifically say
um
and i quote
it is unlikely uh sorry from information
available at the present time however it
is unlikely
that the peter will be disturbed as the
active excavation for the road
construction is unlikely to reach the
depth of the peat now that's the
information we've got at this moment in
time further investigation works we'll
clearly go into that to discover how
much more peat there is potentially
there and whether a road would
potentially affect that so
a decision has been made to follow a
path if you excuse um that terminology
no decision yet has been made as to
whether we build the road or yet yes or
not thanks chair
yeah i just want to say briefly could we
look at the strategic program next step
slide and decide about you know what
steps we can take or how we can be
involved in the scrutiny process by
looking at that it's just a suggestion
yeah
chair if i may suggest
i think there is scope given the amount
of concern that this item has clearly
raised and the fact has council writers
helpfully explain to us there is
a significant
mileage to go on this that this is kept
firmly on the table for future meetings
and that we feed back our concerns and
hopefully we can get some of this um
you know process addressed yeah i mean
there are certain things there
that
um we we we could look at in in more
detail
i mean
you know the consultation
you know
um
can be a consideration
of whether it's
been as stringent as it could have been
um
and there were
there are other questions as well i
think that come out of this
but i think
at the moment it is the preferred option
um
and that is a decision
but as
i think james has just said that there's
a lot of work to be
done
to
actually get it
you know through the planning process
and through
all the stringent tests that
you know the impact statement and so on
so we we
we can as a scrutiny committee look at
that
in in
more detail
what those issues
can entail really
and i think that's probably the best way
that we can
do that but i think we need to set that
out
ourselves first um
and that that needs a bit of a
discussion i think
yeah i know there's all hands up um
so can you keep your remarks
pretty
quickly really
yeah short
well thank you for that summary and it
does seem there's a majority at this
table that's concerned with that um
public engagement
uh i also was informed that the roots
would it was not a request for roots so
i'm i'm wondering how that fed through i
would love to i'd love more information
on that and especially if the decision
between a and f might have been based on
that
it's a fundamental of it i mean i'm not
going to say whether or not you know i i
accept there's a problem that needs a
solution
but if there's two on the table and it's
based on something like that could be
flawed
it's certainly something we need to look
at
um and i i welcome that right
but we're scrutinizing it
sorry i just don't know everyone's
talking about those next steps and
everything um
would it be possible to get a timeline
of those next steps so the committee
could then look at that timeline and
look at that how it fits in with their
meetings going forward and could pick
out certain areas to look at in advance
of them being implemented
yes well we're just looking at the
um
program as i highlighted that we're
preparing a revised project program
so um and there will be a series if even
if i said the next sort of big milestone
is the submission of the planning
application
um on the way to that
excuse me there will be quite a number
of different activities that will be
part of that process
so i think within probably two or three
weeks we'll probably have that revised
program
um we could share it with
certainly soft chair whoever needs to be
shared with um
and then it would if the committee can
identify particular issues that it would
like to discuss or or anything of that
nature then obviously we'd be happy to
do that and obviously if we know in
advance what the the principal concerns
are then hopefully we can provide the
right
information
ahead of time to to sort of focus that
discussion if that would have be of
assistance
thanks jer just just in defense of the
public engagement which seems to be
quite a contentious issue this evening
um
the public engagement number well it
took place during during the pandemic
number one so it couldn't couldn't be an
in-person consultation for obvious
reasons
um ten thousand leaflets were
distributed to local residencies and
residents and businesses
um
direct mail invitations are over 400
contacts which included councillors
local businesses media contacts
stakeholders community groups and
residents
the engagement was shared
by the council on its social media
platforms it was shared by myself as a
ward councillor councillor knew he was a
very very well-known and respected
member of the community in partington
um and by my other colleague councillor
williams so it's not as if this public
engagement was not widely advertised it
really was and we did everything we
possibly could to get as many responses
as we could
um unfortunately and adrian will
i'm sure confirm this as an officer
seeing this amount of responses to a
consultation is not uncommon even for
such a contentious issue now that
doesn't mean that we wouldn't want more
responses to a public consultation of
this nature of course we would um but we
genuinely did in my view as much as we
probably possibly could to get
engagement from the public on this um
and i think it's slightly unfair of
members to suggest that we didn't do
that because in my view we absolutely
did thanks chair
thanks chad um in terms of identifying
what people want to ask about lots of
people ask lots of things can we check
whether those have all been captured
because that might form the start of a
an agenda for our subsequent session on
this
and
i think there's kind of a red herring
thing going on about this the original
um
opinion taking what's done's done
i just don't believe the assertion that
that was used to decide between inf
because 10 said a and 11 said f so it
just wouldn't have been a basis to
decide that i think the key is can we
see in advance what the public
consultation process will be thanks
um i think i'd like to say this partly
to put it on the record um
i don't have an opinion personally about
this going forward i will have an
opinion in my role as counselor um but
as part of scrutiny committee i don't
have an opinion and i don't think that's
our role here to bring our own personal
opinions to it my responses have arisen
today from the presentation that we were
sent a little while ago so i've had a
chance to look at that and that's where
my questions are arisen
and we ask questions with the aim of
giving both this scheme and
all that comes before us
um due diligence and to give legitimacy
to council decisions we have to ask
questions i feel like adrian and james
must feel very bombarded tonight and
that certainly wasn't our intention
but
um as many of us have raised questions
today then perhaps you can see that
actually bringing something scrutiny as
a presentation
going forward i'm not entirely sure how
useful that is to us and certainly the
next time that we engage with andrew i'm
sorry buddy pardon with adrian and james
i would like us to pin down an awful lot
more so that you you have got you know
you you're not just fielding questions
frying at you from all sides
but um
i got the impression james that you you
thought and i may obviously be wrong
here
that
i raised a raise the question for
example are the people who signed the
petition
um for no other reason than to recognize
them in this room tonight as as having
an opinion that should be represented
here and a lot of you know what we ask
maybe will be devil's advocate or you
know
literally in my case quite new to this
business trying to get to grips with the
presentation that we've been given
tonight so just like that putting on the
record that i think that scrutiny
tonight is trying really hard to do its
job
chair can i just add a final point i
think in terms of the decision having
been made
um
you know much like the apocryphal
business of the metropolitan police not
being able to investigate things that
have happened um
i think you know if this committee chose
to do so
we could investigate and scrutinize the
fall of the roman empire if we wanted i
mean there won't be a lot of point but
we could do it we can scrutinize what we
like
and i think we just need to bear that in
mind that because an executive decision
has taken place
it is in fact the role of scrutiny to to
make sure that that's
looked into and that if any process
errors occurred that they don't occur
again
i just wanted to make the point that you
can't always come with pre-planned
questions i think the the presentations
and the discussion that takes place
draws out
points which you then need to ask
questions on so i mean not everybody
tends to read the papers when they get
them
yeah so they should do yes
uh chair yes i'm i'm sure abs absolutely
i mean that that's the matter of records
so i'm sure we can um put that in you
know kind of hopefully an easy format
and
um and in particular as i say
uh we will be look you know we will be
doing this program um
and you know
it's going to be probably
uh you know
it's at least 18 months so it'll be a
decent period so um as i say very very
happy to to come back and and you know
address any queries
please did
uh it was just a minor point i was just
going to remind people again to please
use your microphones just because um
people who are watching on uh the stream
they'll only be able to hear you if you
have your microphone on
yeah
yes point taking um
right
so
we'll we will come back with with
something and we'll circulate it amongst
members and uh we'll try and
um
do as much scrutiny
as
as we can
um
with the resources that we have
um
so
if we
move on to
chair chair are you okay to excuse
adrian life
yeah i'm sorry yeah um and thanks thanks
very much for for coming
much appreciated so thank you
councillors yeah
right so
uh we'll move on to item nine it's a
budget scrutiny report um
and
it has been circulated
and we
if it's agreed tonight this will go
forward to the
uh executive at their next meeting
um
has anybody got any comments or is
everybody in agreement with the content
of the
uh report
yeah
oh jed
yeah i think it's um a decent summary
just going back to comment made earlier
um there was stuff in here about
people will come back to us on the two
and a half percent inflation assumption
and what impact a major change in that
assumption would be which evidently
there's been a major change and
whatever the other question there was um
i raised at the start oh yeah the are we
on a fixed are we on a fixed energy
tariff or not so if that isn't known now
could we get written answers to to those
two questions please
thank you and
um
i think when we discussed
budget scrutiny
there was a
a general call for if any members have
any further suggestions for cost savings
um could could they make them i'm
guessing none of those have been no
further submissions put forward through
through the committee so i'd hope that
we're all agreed that this is a
reasonable summary and that we're all
agreed
this would go forward thank you
is everybody okay then yeah
thank you
and we now go on to
um
[Applause]
the work program
which
is on here
um
i think
i know you wanted to
say something louise um i'm not quite
sure
what it was
but we can hang it on to this work
program
[Music]
this a discussion you want to have in
labor groups
[Music]
okay
um i've got some issues um
as always
i've got some issues about um
the presentations we've been getting um
and
the amount of time they take up
and in terms of them of people reporting
to us
but was not um been in a position to
necessarily scrutinize them
so for example tonight when we had our
presentation by uh
adrian fisher
um
it was really i as i understand it for
our information report
was that case
it hasn't been brought to us as an issue
that we've raised for scrutiny
um so i know that that is part of the
work programming and that we can change
we can look at that going forward
we did get some representation from the
public
to ask
for us to look at the scrutiny of
the relief road all right
i hadn't appreciated that
that's why it was on the agenda right
okay um and the other thing is um
a lot of a lot of the things that are
that are my concerns at the moment have
come up during our scrutiny review and
alex perhaps you could remind everybody
when the date for the next secretary
review meeting is
i believe it's next monday i don't we'll
just encourage everybody who's on
scrutiny to come along to that meeting
because it's been really interesting you
know the people on this it's been a
really interesting and enlightening
experience and it's quite exciting and i
think you know we
hope dave and jill and everyone else who
was on it would agree you know there's
lots of exciting things proposed that we
could do
to
make these meetings as meaningful as as
possible and i think at the moment when
there's
so much that these scrutinizing you know
we're so pulled in so many directions it
would be really good to pin down some of
the things that we're looking at
um
yeah so that's all i wanted to say
chair can i just mention that given the
concern that's been raised at this
meeting that perhaps even if it's just
an item for noting there's no particular
update carrington relief road might
be worth shoving on the agenda next time
i think it will need to go on go go go
go on the agenda i agree yeah no
no
i i
i was thinking that's a given right
from from the discussion we've had
tonight
i'm wondering and please it's out of
ignorance here that i have quite a lot
of issues um with residents and the
state of um their housing association
houses um with
things like damp uh dilapidation mold i
i don't know if it's something that we
should be scrutinizing here because i'm
you know but it does feel to me that
it's something perhaps we should as a
body look at or
ask questions about and i just wonder if
that's something that would be
considered
we
i think as
the vice chair said we
we can look at anything really
and um
obviously particularly
those organizations that work within
trafford like housing trusts
those bodies that we
you know
connected to
in many many ways
um
which housing association is it
it's not one specific i i have i have
the number i think i have one a very
large percentage of housing association
my warden and it's over
for at least three
i would say there's issues and uh
and and quite how they address them uh
perhaps it's something that we should
ask
well i think if you had specific housing
associations we could if we so wish that
if the committee wanted to we could
invite them to
address that i mean you know you've
experienced how hard it is getting any
sense out of trafford housing trust in
terms of the cladding business
they are one of the better ones yes um
and unfortunately the situations i know
you'll be aware julian of um
that we have in this country really with
these housing associations is that they
don't answer to anybody
um some will you know i've generally
found thg okay i'd challenge you to get
anybody from her world valley round a
table um
you know as my gray hairs will attest
so i i think it might yeah definitely
worth looking at but i wouldn't be too
hopeful okay that's all i'd say
thank you
thanks chad am i right to say this
agenda item is asking members are there
things that we should be scrutinizing to
add to the agenda
we're open to um
if you consider things if they crop up
sure if i could
or
always actually said that yeah
absolutely i could float one it might
just be me um but it'd be interested in
other members um are interested in
scrutinizing this at some point in the
future
i think
there is a presumption and a forecast of
increased proportion of vehicles on the
road are going to be electric
and
i know that currently the amount of
provision for charging um ev vehicles is
almost non-existent
um so if we increase it tenfold that's
going from almost non-existent to 10
times always our existence so i'd be
interested
in
a
the council's view of what the likely
demand is going to be over say five to
ten years and
how is the charging capacity going to be
available to residents
um because what i've seen so far
i it fills me with some dread um now i
don't know whether that's of interest to
other members or whether it's not
important enough or big enough for
subject for scrutiny but um i'd
appreciate people's views
that's i'd second that from a
uh a personal perspective when i'm
looking at a change in my car
and the availability of charging points
is a really big issue and i don't know
what the situation is so you know i
would definitely second the um that'd be
nice to be scrutinized
would the best thing
would be to write to the
the leader to
uh see what
um
you know
what the policy is in terms of
um progressing
charging points across trafford it's a
simple question
um it's more about the strategy because
if the solution is public charging
points my personal opinion is it will
fail
not slightly or just it'll fundamentally
fail
it's about what the solutions are to
enabling people to charge i suspect an
awful lot of those will be people
charging their own vehicle from their
own domestic residence which is fine if
you've got a drive not so fine if you
haven't um so it's more about what's the
strategy what's the demand implication
like and
how are we going to how are we going to
meet it one bit of that will be public
available charging up stations but it
won't be the solution
no it's shareable just to interject
it'll be a policy decided within the
police team it's a question for the
officers in the place team as opposed to
questions for the leader
yeah
well we
you know if you
frame a question we'll get it sent to
the right people so do i send that to
you chair yeah maybe me and alex yeah
thanks thank you
i just wondered if this uh if you
believe that we need to have another
presentation from the homelessness
um again next month
i'm very happy to see the data i'm just
not sure that it's worth that lady's
time in coming here and if we see the
date i agree um
yeah i think i think if we're getting
the information and
obviously she she's offered first oh i
appreciate that and she said no no no
we'll make it unstable
if there's a sudden spike we can always
have yeah yeah we can
so i i i if we
um
say to her
that
um you know we're happy with the
written report
and we'll call on you um when necessary
alex
uh yes just uh picking up on that point
um caroline did say uh that she was
really happy to tailor that to me any
particular trends that people are
looking for so um if gender was gendered
one that people wanted on because i've
captured that before but if there's any
other items i
then
uh
please email me and i'll put that in the
request to it or would you like me to
ask exact for a list of all the
indicators and then you can select from
those
they were in the
board
in the deck that were circulated but if
you can capture by default they are
provided year on year if they can't do a
mirror and you're fine but by default it
can be done year on year sure because
otherwise it's a number yeah it's just
kind of like
that list that they provided wasn't even
exhaustive so they have a lot more so i
don't know would you like to see the
whole raft and then select what you
would like to see or do you want to just
work on what you've seen so far does
that meet a lot of your needs
the information that was that shows you
know it was the kind of thing we need as
but as it's been said i think we just
need some kind of comparative to
so that information as a graph would be
very useful to see trend
rather than snapshot which we're getting
meeting and thank you all
for your attendance
um
and have a safe journey home
thank you